[Music]
we could beam anybody in 4k volumetric
resolution in under a second anywhere in
the world
[Applause]
[Music]
the way we meet is ever evolving in
person is great but with distance and
restrictions it's not always an option
and after a few years of talking through
our screens zoom fatigue is very real
what if there were a middle ground
proto is vying to be just that
so i'm going to interview the ceo in la
without ever having to leave new york
david are you there
hello i'm here
tell me how is this working how are you
doing this right now i'm beaming in from
los angeles into a device that we have
in new york right before you
and i'm beaming my 4k volumetric
resolution real-time hologram from 3 000
miles away so we can communicate i'm
standing in a seven foot tall four and a
half foot wide two foot deep hollow
portation machine and the content that's
being captured is being sent
near latency free to you in real time
like i'm really there before you it's so
what we've all dreamed of since we
watched smart house as children but i'm
curious how did you come up with the
idea i used to run a department of what
used to be one of the world's largest
hologram entertainment companies and one
of the things that we were known for
doing was digitally resurrecting late
legends to posthumously perform on
stages all over the world but it wasn't
until i started beaming the living that
made me think i'm living on the west
coast and my parents who are both
getting older they live on the east
coast i've got young children so i
thought wouldn't it be cool if they
could just beam into each other's lives
and so the idea for proto was formed
[Music]
talk to me about how you've
differentiated your product over the
years totally self-contained you don't
need any external projectors you don't
need any external monitors you don't
need any external cameras the other
thing is the lights are on in the room
how about that shadows never existed in
hologram before because everything
happened in darkness and now with light
we can have shadows we have reflections
we have depth and dimension
i'm able to beam from wherever i am i
could be in my home i could be in my
living room i could be in my office and
we're using an iphone these days as the
camera source right so now a single
iphone and our free app can allow the
person to be
captured and then materialized anywhere
in the world
[Music]
let's talk a little bit about some of
the barriers to entry here how much are
we talking cost wise and what would you
say is the education level and
familiarity with technology needed to to
use your product the device itself
because it's completely self-contained
uh doesn't take a very long time to
learn but the costs you could rent them
for as little as 15 or 25 000 per event
and we sell them for 65 000 and up
[Music]
what is your plan for expansion and
maybe increasing that accessibility a
little bit so that you know mom in new
jersey can have this product in her
house
well we just announced a miniature unit
we're calling it the proto-m it is
one-fifth scale of the device that i'm
standing in right now so it's like a
little uh wonka vision
[Music]
what are the other use cases obviously i
can see you right now but what other fun
things can we see this is a museum
quality device and why not project
museum quality artwork inside
and then nfts they are being used in
galleries right now all over the world
and as we continue to evolve the
technology as a way to try on your
clothes at a department store without
actually having to wear them it's a
full-size hologram mirror it's my dream
come true and you've also talked about
expansion into the music space tell me
what that would look like sean diddy
combs we beamed him out of his home
we beamed kane brown during the iheart
music festival
but it's not just for musical artists or
entertainers it's for ceos
[Music]
what does the future look like holograms
are going to be commonplace and it's
really incredible because you know there
are things that you just can't see on a
zoom call or hear on a phone call this
is real
i think people should be able to walk
around i feel like people should be able
to move and engage it's just a much more
interactive engaging experience so we're
also going to get a little bit smaller
we're going to be in cars we're going to
be in the home we're going to be in the
conference rooms one of our devices is
right now at the university of central
florida where professors and educators
are using it to teach future healthcare
providers how to treat and diagnose
their patients through the proto window
my focus is on connecting people and
evolving the company and making this
thing as great as possible
[Music]
you